彭飞律师你好，
我现在呢是有个问题，
我先说一下我现在的一个基本情况哈，
也就是我今年呢35岁，
我父母呢是在一个四线的小城市，
是一个单亲妈妈的家庭，
然后我自己呢，
现在是在一线城市工作嘛，
是一个自营的一个嗯状态，
然后年收入呢大概是在100左右，
然后目前自己资产呢是有一点，
但是呢是无车无房，
然后家里呢是给不了帮助的，
然后我跟我男朋友呢是同岁，
然后在一起大概是一年半时间，
然后男朋友呢，
他之前是在那个，
呃，
加拿大那边有绿卡，
然后在那边呢是呃有过一个有一段婚姻，
但是他已经离了，
离了之后呢，
有一个小孩是归女方那边的，
他现在是回国之后呢，
是做的是一个金融行业，
他的年收入大概是在300左右，
然后目前他的资产呢是2000左右，
然后他的父母呢，
是一个相当于是体制内的嘛，
可能家庭资产大概有一个小目标的样子，
然后我跟他在一起这一年半呢，
他给我付出大概是30个左右，
然后在今年三月份呢，
我跟男朋友呢有过一个宝宝，
然后当时呢，
他是以嗯，
他的工作不太稳定为理。
时候呢，
就是让我把这个宝宝给拿掉了，
然后拿掉的时候呢，
你也没有给陪伴和情绪价值，
就相当于是给了正常的这些产生的费用嘛，
然后目前呢，
就是在今年10月份到现在，
就是在上个月，
然后不小心呢就又抢了宝宝，
然后现在就是我男朋友的态度呢，
就是嗯，
如果要生下这个宝宝呢的话是可以的，
但是呢，
他没有办法，
目前是没有办法跟我结婚的，
给的理由呢，
就是因为目前工作太忙了，
因为我们是异地，
基本上他的工作是全国甚至全球，
有些时候到处去飞嘛，
然后基本上一个月在一起的时间大概10天左右，
你有可能是没有办法给陪伴，
然后也没有办法在身边，
然后要生孩子的话是没有办法结婚，
然后第二呢，
他给出的一个观点是，
每个月会给到孩子5000块钱的抚养费，
但是在孕期或者生产期间呢，
就是没有陪伴，
还有就是所产生的其他的费用呢，
是需要我自己来负责的，
就是这种情况，
然后我现在呢，
就是有一个困难，
就是。
因为我自己目前的工作是算是一个半岁的嘛，
如果我要生下这个宝宝的话，
可能会对我的工作的收入会有影响，
如果我现在选择拿掉这个宝宝的话，
就很有可能，
因为现在年纪在这了嘛，
就很有可能很难再做母亲了，
就相当于是这种情况，
然后我现在就是不知道该怎么办，
我到底是要把这个宝宝给生下来呢，
还是说继续跟他在一起，
然后继续保持这种关系，
然后慢慢的推进婚姻，
还是说我直接把这个宝宝拿掉，
然后就不用再选择。
当妈妈这条路这个事情我给你讲讲这个事情的本质，
然后你自己来做这个决定啊，
这个事情的本质就是一句话，
说明白了这个男的他没有怎么看上咱们，
他可能是比说咱们原生家庭跟他不匹配，
你妈妈这边也帮不上任何忙，
他的原生家庭有一个小目标，
然后呢，
咱们的职业是属于自营，
自营那说白了就是自己是个小老板是吧，
他呢，
是属于那种你你都说了，
全球各地到处飞的精英人士啊，
年若二三百个换一个人士，
所以其实说到底了就是他不是不想结婚，
只是不想跟咱们结婚，
而且在他的眼里看的话，
咱们的价值是很低的，
就凭他一年挣300万的人，
他给孩子抚养费，
一个月给5000，
就表示什么花花的眼里的话，
说句难听点的话，
你可能就值这个价位，
对不起，
老我这可能说出来伤人了，
就是我们要看清这个现状，
我们才能够综合来判断，
才能够做人生的选择。
你想要嫁进他们家这一路的话，
可能是很难的，
但凡是比如说他爸妈又给他介绍一个门当户对的，
或者他自己在工作当中又遇到了一个带出去更有面子的，
在他的生命中对他更有帮助的人的话，
他就把你给踹了，
你想要嫁进他们家这条路的话，
会很难会有。
很长的路要走，
所以我们我把这个心理预期给打掉，
先把这个心理期给打掉了之后，
我们回到现实，
回到现实我们我们作为一个女性，
我们自己能够在一线城市能够有年入100万这样的收入，
我们自己本身很有能力的，
对吧，
自己是很优秀的。
好在这种情况下的话，
我们看看我们自己能不能在打掉了跟他步入婚姻的这个心理预期之后，
回到我自己身上，
我愿不愿意说我自己现在收入也可以，
有一定的存款，
我愿不愿意带一个生命来到这个世界，
我给他足够的爱，
我给他足够的耐心，
我去好好的爱他，
如果这件事情我自己愿意干的话，
我就当这个男人，
嗯，
我就找了一个普通的男人嘛，
他一个月能够5000，
那也可以呀，
也很好啊，
最起码比那种一分钱不出的人要好多了呀，
我也不寄希望于许我将来要跟你结婚，
但最起码这个孩子可能是他的血脉，
他的社会资源，
我的孩子还能用，
爷爷奶奶的社会资源，
我的孩子也能用，
你要是抱着这种想法的话，
咱就可以生，
但是如果目前生的话，
嗯，
就可能在怀孕到生产，
我可能会耽误，
大概有至少得有须半年时间吧，
对吧？
嗯，
你跟他谈这个事儿，
你得跟他谈，
你说真的很爱。
爱你啊，
但是对于未来的话，
我们谁也说不准，
我现在确实年纪也到这儿了，
而且我们两个人是第二次怀孕了，
我如果再打掉这个孩子的话，
可能以后我就没有办法做妈妈了，
所以我想状态的话，
我是想生下这个孩子的，
但是我确实也面临着这样的实际的困难，
我可能有半年的时间是没有办法挣钱的，
你看这种情况下，
你可不可以给我一定的这种安全感，
给我一定的这个保障，
当然我知道这件事情是需要我们共同去决定的，
我也不是说啊，
拿着我怀孕了，
我去要挟你或者怎么怎么样的，
就这事儿的话可以跟他谈，
比如说他愿意拿个30万，
20万、
50万的，
我觉得都很好是吧？
嗯，
这件事情嗯，
之前跟他聊过，
因为我说无非就是你出钱，
我出力，
还有时间和精力，
再加上我自己的这些耽务的东西嘛，
我说那你能不能再呃跟我打一个时间差，
就是相当于是在我在怀孕生产这段时间，
对吧，
然后你能不能就是帮助一下我，
等我度过这个时期后期，
至于你给孩子多少，
我觉得我也有能力呀，
那是你的事，
我说在这个时间差之内，
你能不能帮帮我一下，
然后他给出的一个态度呢，
就是说目前这个情况，
他只能够给5000，
然后不管以后。
我发生什么事情，
然后需要多的开销也好，
或者少的开销也好，
然后也只能够给到一个月5000的这个一个态度，
然后其他的呢，
不会再多给我觉得这个事儿你现在是几个月，
你现在两个多月，
要不你再去医院去看看，
就检查一下你自己的身体状况，
如果你身体状况各方面指标都非常好的话，
也不是说以后就不能做母亲了，
也没到这种程度，
意思就是我还是可以去医院那边多跑几，
比如说我是还有生育权利的话，
我现在最好的选择就是把这个宝宝拿掉后直接切断，
对吧，
不要有这些幻想，
或者说走了一条嗯，
未婚，
然后生下宝宝，
一个单亲妈妈的这条路，
对吧？
是这样子的啊，
我其实捕捉到的消息就是这个男的啊，
嗯，
可能表面上看起来很风光，
然后表面他高宝名，
他原生家庭很好，
他家里有一个小目包，
但这个男的会特别抠门，
对，
因为我跟他在一年半，
反正总共在我身上的付出大概就有30个左右，
就这个也不算抠门了，
就是说他给孩子就只愿意给5000块钱这个事儿的话，
就是觉得他这个人情感上应该是比较能说好听点理性颖，
说难听点淡漠。
那如果你跟。
他生了一个孩子，
将来的话人是这样子的，
就是我再让你不期待，
不期待你心里是很难打掉自己那个期待的，
你一旦对这个白人始终抱有一种期待的话，
但是最终就会落空，
你就会很痛苦，
可能就是真的是见得多了之后，
我现在能够预见得到的就是你的痛苦，
你的痛苦是来自于你不可避免的对这个男人还会有期待，
你期待着他有没有可能真的就跟你结婚，
你期待着这个男人说一年挣300万，
嗯，
400万的时候，
会不会对孩子多付出一点啊，
你期待着这个男人会不会在孩子出生了之后，
觉得孩子很可爱，
然后就多来看看你，
多来看看孩子啊，
这一定是你那个功内心不可避免内心可能会会有这种想法，
然后刚刚我看那个很多很多朋友，
他说可能我是被2+1的那个，
但是其实这个是不是的，
因为他在加拿大那边的一个离婚证我看过的，
然后她国内的这个婚姻状态我也查过的，
目前呢是一个我俩都是单身的情况，
然后春节的时候他已经入我妈妈，
当时我们相处呢，
就是一个正常男女朋友这样的关系，
说过如果不想走婚恋这条路的话，
就不要耽误彼此时间，
因为现在年纪也大了，
然后我无论你条件再怎么。
对吧，
我只想是做一个正常的女性谈恋爱，
结婚生子，
而不是说跟你玩一段时间，
觉得你条件怎么样，
然后又怎么怎么样，
当时是把这些所有情况了解清楚之后才决定在一起的，
是这么的一个样子，
你知道对于他来说，
他跟你在一起的时候，
他没有生育焦虑，
没有这个经，
因为他他为什么跟我提出5000这个呢？
因为他说他之前加拿大不是也有过一个宝宝嘛，
然后那个宝宝现在是跟着他妈妈在，
他说他给那个宝宝也是一个月5000块钱，
反正他算的就是他说一个月5000，
然后现在也没有说。
就是态度，
他给我的态度一直是很爱美的，
知道吧，
他也没有很斩钉截铁的说我们俩就分开，
然后把这个宝宝拿掉，
也没有说我们俩就在一起好好生下这个宝宝，
就是你要生也可以。
其实她已经态度很明确了，
你都已经跟她说，
在你怀孕生产这个过程当中，
她能不能帮帮你，
她说只能给5000，
其实这就是一个态度，
她只是不想做那个恶人，
不想直接说让你。
你要听懂一个人话语背后的真正的意图，
如果他不想让你打掉这个孩子的话，
作为一个男人，
而且他收入那么高，
他在恋爱的过程中都愿意为你花30万，
那这个时候他不管怎么说的话，
他多多少少都应该啊，
答应一点是吧？
那在你要求他给你帮助的情况下，
依然坚持给你5000块钱，
这背后就是让你要，
你要理解这背后的用意，
反正其实跟你聊了，
我大概也能够。
嗯，
知道大概是怎么回事，
因为之前一直看不清的可能，
嗯，
就是姐妹啊，
咱们这个事儿呢，
就是退一万步讲，
假设啊，
假设我们就去了那个穿买衣服的地方，
人家穿白衣服的人说，
嗯，
你的身体条件不太好，
建议不要，
咱们也要调整自己的心态，
调整自己什么心态呢？
首先我自己有能力养得起是吧，
我自己能够做一个小老板，
作为一个女性，
30多岁，
我能一年挣100多万的话，
我已经具备了一个就是作为单亲妈妈拒富留子的女性的这样一个能力，
也要保控自己的心态，
是我心里就已经打算去富留子了，
之后假设我将来我孩子出生了啊，
就是一路绿灯，
孩子很健康很可爱，
孩子很有灵性，
很聪明，
那说不准将来爷爷奶奶就喜欢孩子呢，
是吧，
他最起码不够对吧，
不会来陷害你们吧，
最起码说，
嗯，
有点什么事儿的时候，
还能找爷爷奶奶帮帮忙吧，
就是你心里一旦不寄希望于跟这个男人有一个什么婚姻，
跟这个男人有一个什么很好的感情的时候，
你反而可以很从容的去呃，
借势，
很从容的去运用很多的资源，
那个时候你的心态就不一样了。
那个时候你的心态是我自。
己做的决定，
我想要一个小孩，
哎，
幸好我的这个小孩的基因DNA，
他们家条件还不错，
爷爷奶奶对吧，
还有一定的这个资源，
还有一定的学识，
还能帮衬，
就这意思，
就调整好自己的心态，
你的这个状态才会更好，
我我我我。
嗯，
就是这个都是后期的事情，
有可能会往这个好的方向发生，
但是也有可能会是一个很不确定的，
嗯，
一个状态对吧，
有的时候人就是这样子的，
就是当你这边对人家没有任何期待，
没有任何怨言的时候，
当你这边把自己日子过得很好，
你你生完孩子了，
你照样可以经营，
你照样一年可以挣百十来万，
对不对，
你到时候妈妈妈做到身边再雇个保姆，
雇个保姆的话，
可能一个月8000的1万的，
对吧，
你照样可以过得很好，
风生水起，
如果你把孩子抚养的很好的话，
或许那一头还也热闹，
或许那头让爷爷奶奶看到了之后还只爱的不行呢，
对不对，
那你不要寄希望于说这个男人会对你爱的不行，
不要寄希望于这个男人会对孩子爱的不行，
因为他上一把我们帮你演算过一把了，
他对他前妻生的那个孩子也这样吧，
所以你当你不希望于这个男人对你会有什么反馈的时候，
你心态平和，
就老杨自己养着是吧，
就是也，
但前提条件是人家白大褂说建议你不要打，
如果白大褂说可以不要，
那咱真的没必要冒这么大的风险啊，
嗯，
明白明白，
行了，
行行，
谢谢。
再见，
谢谢啊，
再见啊，
拜拜，
我们听所有的东西的话，
我们都去透过这个，
透过这个现象去摸他的这个心理，
摸他的真实的想法，
你想这样一个年入二三百万的精英男士，
家里面资产一个亿的小小目标的这样一个条件，
他给他加拿大的孩子一个月就给5000块钱，
你就能够看到这个人的人生底色了，
你就能够看到这个人他对待自己的血脉，
对待自己的孩子，
他是一个什么样的态度了，
人是很难改变的，
不是说对吧，
他对待加拿大的孩子一个月给5000人民币，
他对我的孩子就能够更大方一点吗？
不会的。